التوافق الاوروبيه على كييف ياتي وسط
تحضيرات متزايده من حشد روسي لشن هجوم
واسع في الذكرى الاولى للحرب وقال رئيس
الوزراء البولندي
ماتيوسكي ان الاوكرانيين لا يستبعدون
هجوما من اراضي بيلاروسيا ومحاوله حصار من
الغرب وان الرئيس الروسي فلاديمر بوتين
يخطط لشن هجوم جديد على محورين او ثلاثه
وقد يهاجم كياف مره اخرى
اذا يتوقع المسؤولون مسؤلون اوكرانيون
واوروبيون ان تشن موسكو هجوما عسكريا
واسعا في غضون اسابيع قليله امين مجلس
الامن القومي الاوكراني قال ان الهجوم
الروسي قد يبدا من الشمال والجنوب والشرق
كما حدث في بدايه الحرب وخلال الاسابيع
الثلاثه المقبله اما وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني فقال خلال حديث لوسائل اعلام
الفرنسيه ان تقديراتهم تشير الى ان روسيا
استدعت قرابه 500 الف من جنودها الاحتياط
وليس 300 الف كما اعلن عنه او تم الاعلان
عنه رسميا وزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيه ذكرت
اخيرا انها باتت تملك ما يكفي من صواريخ
اسكندر القادره على تنفيذ اي مهمه عسكريه
ومنظومات صاروخيه قادره على ضرب اهداف
يتجاوز مداها 300 كيلومتر وان الاسابيع
الماضيه شهدت مناورات روسيه بيلاروسيه
البحر الاسود ايضا شهد وفقا للمخابرات
الاوكرانيه تغييرات في نشاط القوات
البحريه الروسيه وقالت الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه ان نشاط الروسي الحربي هناك
يزيد وينقص بسرعه وحاملات الصواريخ تتحرك
في هذا ذهابا وايابا